[Music]
in a world where every franchise has at
least one dud never leave the cave
without him John Wick will once again
pull off the impossible and an excellent
fourth film so if it wasn't clear by now
we're never gonna let this franchise
stop have you given any thought
where this ends nope keanu's gonna be 80
and we'll watch him snap next in a
tactical diaper John Wick chapter four
chapter three ended with John growling
the word yeah
yeah
yeah now pick up exactly where he left
off yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
for another wall-to-wall Banger of an
action film that's once again about
trying to leave the Assassin world
because he clicked I agree without
reading the terms and conditions in a
Thrill Ride that runs for just two hours
and 49 minutes because if your wit goes
hard for a full three hours you have to
seek medical attention also everyone's
wearing a vibranium suit this time so it
takes 10 shots to drop a single goon
John Wick is back and with every
assassin on his tail he can travel from
New York to Osaka to Berlin to Paris
without incident but once he's
teleported to his next fighting game
stage ooh boy look the [__] out he's
determined to let anything except his
words do the talking
probably because he's got CTE so bad he
can't string together a full sentence
oh
as this human throw pillow takes an
endless dream of physical punishment and
personal criticism
because of you I had to kneel
your father
kill Koji
just because of his never-ending quest
to kill everyone on planet Earth no one
not even you can kill everyone
Counterpoint yes he clearly can
watch John set his sights on the Marquee
yet another overmatched European fancy
boy who you just know is evil because he
hangs out next to a skill model of a
city and only villains get to do that
Jon will also cross paths with his old
friend Kane and continue running up the
scoreboard against the hearing and
Visually Impaired Donnie Yen shines in
another blind role because it would be
straight up unfair to let him fight if
he could actually see
they'll tangle with the tracker a guy
who's hunting John because he's too
broke to upgrade his phone watch and
dismay as he spends the film sniping
from the edge of the map like a [__]
camper
plus thrill at the return of Ian
mcshane's Winston and recoil at the
debut of Ian mcshane's Winston's new
bleached teeth whoa the veneers or the
tanning bed one of them's gotta go
forget the characters this is all about
the action and man do they deliver
featuring some good old-fashioned
horseplay
the one that's just like my Japanese
animes
the one that confirms they turned off
car damage
the wad where they're just playing
Hotline Miami
the one where the stunt guys get to
really earn their paycheck
and the one where they all sit down to
play the Assassin version of Magic the
Gathering blades
don't you guys have to like tap land
first or something sorry it's always
looked way too boring to learn after
killing roughly 10 000 goons over the
last three films watch jaw and start to
take his toll on the global assassin
industry forcing them to inflate the
wages the lottery just went up higher
poorly trained and experienced scabs
and you're not wave after wave of
trainees with a maybe five percent shot
at getting through their first shift
alive to the point where they're so
desperate for new hires they have to
advertise on FM radio this golden hit
goes out to you Mr Wick come on know
people we're gonna have to do a lot
better also enter the code Warriors
ripoff and check out to receive 20 off
your next funeral so return to the
Relentless franchise that's got that dog
in it because now that you've seen John
Wick avenge a dog adopt a dog and team
up with a dog enjoy this new spin where
he fights a dog
then befriends a dog
because at the beginning they killed his
dog dog damn dog R.I.P to a real one
starring
Ted Theodore Shogun Winston checks out
Larry the table guy another Skarsgard
you're in your element Donnie it has
indeed been an honor my friend now
Phyllis I want a clean duel I've got a
lot of money writing on this The
Notebook get over here and have a
pleasant stay South American Ninja
Warrior the Atkins diet
and stay
foreign
[Music]
2.
you know you may think it's weird so
many people are still dancing but this
is actually the least disturbing thing
that happens in a German nightclub hey
screen junkies we gathered experts in
law psychology and Firearms to analyze
how John Wick would fare in the real
world there's not anything in the law
right now about an extra penalty for
death by library book click the Box on
the right to watch now
I refuse to read these requests if you
don't say please my voice is how it
feels to chew five gum rock paper
scissors grenade launcher one two three
four I declare a thumb war